For this second
week, week 2, we'll
be taking you from the pretty
straight-forward process
of creating images on a flatbed
scanner to what you probably
expected in the first place
when you enrolled in our class
using a camera and lens to
capture images of your work
in the lab.
We'll first take a look at what
kind of equipment you'll need.
We'll look at specific
lighting next week.
And we'll go over the very
basics of making an image.
Because this course is about
photographing certain material
with a certain
scale, we're going
to be very specific
in our suggestions
for a camera and lens
and for other equipment.
These photographs
will be staged.
You have control.
You're not going to
wonder what the image will
look like after it's done.
You will see your
process and your thinking
as you create the set-up
and light it and compose it.
We're also going to
review the important issue
of getting the right exposure
for our specific requirements.
Now we're assuming you already
have some basic knowledge
of picture making.
And, we'll just be
modifying what you hopefully
already know.
If you're really brand
new to all of this,
you'll find some useful
websites on our resource page.
SO FIRST YOUR CAMERA: You
don't a camera with all sorts
of bells and whistles.
You just need one which
will take various lenses
and that will allow you to
change your ISO, aperture,
and shutter settings.
And most important,
one that will
create a large enough image
measured in file size that
could be submitted, let's
say, for a publication,
or even a cover submission.
You will generally need, for
example, about a 27 meg file.
So something like 300 dpi for an
eight and half by eleven cover.
So you need a camera that
will give you that size image.
NOW FOR YOUR LENS: You'll
need a 105 macro lens.
This particular
lens will allow you
to get close to your
material or device,
basically using macro
photographic techniques.
Don't use enlarging
filters on a normal lens:
The quality of the
optics just doesn't
compare to the optics of
a very fine macro lens.
You'll also need a tripod and I
suggest getting a quick release
mechanism so that you
can take your camera on
and off the tripod easily.
I'm not going to suggest
a copy stand, which
I see around many labs.
Using a copy stand where
the camera is placed only
in one position really
limits your point of view
and we don't want to do that.
You'll see in our
discussion of point of view
about having the ability
to move the camera around
on a tripod, which not
only slows you down, which
is a good thing, but it
teaches you to learn to see
and encourages you to look
carefully at your material.
Finally, I'm also suggesting
that you use your computer
to decide on the various
settings for exposure.
You'll use a software to
make the right settings
and you'll store the images
right onto your computer, not
a card in your camera.
Make sure you get the right
software for your camera.
But, for those of you who
decide not to use software,
you'll just have to learn how
to set all of those settings
within your camera.
Okay, the best way to go
about learning all of this
is to make a picture.
So, we'll work with a
device you've seen before:
The inside of a music box.